how's it going bros my name is peter pan
welcome to red pepper all right I'm
gonna sit down for this video just so
that you know what [ __ ] you you can't
control me that was so unnecessary
this screw got loose I'm pretty sure
this is gonna bite me in the ass layer
show more region is it just me or was
PewDiePie about to vape no what's the
name of the music in the beginning I
don't [ __ ] know just check the
description like everyone [ __ ] else
darude sandstorm
he's wearing the same shirt in the other
laughing challenge vid yeah I don't know
buy you brush but sometimes I wear the
same outfit twice I know it's a fashion
police please don't arrest me or
anything like that
hey I bet you're sitting your [ __ ]
sweat pants with your [ __ ] Cheetos
all over your shopsite I'm sorry
what's wrong with muching anime same
he's just an immature nearsighted person
who thinks watching enemy is a weird
thing it's the same concept as Western
cartoon but some people just don't get
that you sound like one of those people
that preach about marijuana is so much
better than alcohol I don't understand
how it couldn't be illegal it's so
healthy feeling good for you i watch
enemy eye I make sarcastic jokes I love
that I could make a top-ten enemy list
and I would having a full-on erection
the whole time but I like to make jokes
you know humor I love Zelda it's one of
my favorite animes think about it this
way if I say something that's a bit out
of the ordinary
maybe you should go like hey maybe he's
being sarcastic oh my god
I thought I was the only one with cream
phobia hate putting cream on it's so
crazy
Thank You Clara Sofia I hate creams so
much I feel like I'm gonna puke this is
so [ __ ] gross [ __ ] creams YouTube
hole oh man YouTube horror is probably
one of my favorite videos it got taken
down for copyright because of offensive
material it was in YouTube's a call it
was the the song that I used like I
bought the license for the song but
technically if it's seen as offensive
material the license gets void
it's really weird I'm working on to get
it back up you listen to Nickelback
remember what I was talking about being
so sarcastic
I mean honestly Nickelback is not that
bad it's just they look like [ __ ]
idiots
and I'm music is about the ears but like
do you really want to listen to this guy
in your ears
bring back pizzas everything I love
those videos they were great I don't
want to make them anymore the reason why
is because I upload every single day and
for me to make one of those videos in
one day is a hell a lot of a job like
twice it happened that I got a panic
attack from doing it because my body was
just so tired of doing all this crazy
[ __ ] cuz I am doing everything and it's
just any time I think about doing a new
episode I keep thinking about how [ __ ] I
feel and I'm like I'm not enjoying this
process of making this video the result
is great but making the video is
horrible and it's not worth it and I
don't feel like doing it sorry I have so
much more respect for him now that he
listens to Nickelback are they are you
guys sarcastic now he's still with
Marzia first if me and my duster broke
up you would know about it like stop
trying to read into small things it's so
weird
go back to the way you were in 2015
everyone on the Internet is always
preaching so much about you shouldn't
say this person is fat or you shouldn't
say this person is this and that but for
some reason everyone feels so entitled
to tell someone how to act like go back
to the way you were in 2015 that's
[ __ ] weird as hell to say to someone
like and you have the weirdest [ __ ]
avatar like [ __ ] off honestly why why
the body suit thing because of comments
like this if you defy hates and says a
dramas worst thing then why did he make
drama with wit ksi the next day well
case I tweeted me and I just responded I
don't see how that is me making drama
it even so like being ksi are known good
terms we don't hate each other you can
disagree with someone and still be fine
everyone else is blowing this [ __ ] up so
much more than it is and that was part
of the point of me making the drama
video and
I was talking about but no one seems to
care anyway [ __ ] I [ __ ] everyone Jesus
cry for me you will be best forever you
did an awesome job and I find your Vitas
still better and better thank you for
everything you do for us that's very
sweet thank you I was so happy with
their feedback that I got from the old
versus new PewDiePie video I feel like
I'm finally at a point where I am proud
of the content that I make like this guy
I want him to play amnesia again even
though a lot of people want me to make a
lot of other type of videos I'm making
the videos that I'll enjoy making sure I
could still upload another part of happy
wheels and people would enjoy it even
though I did God knows how many but I
wouldn't enjoy making those videos I
feel like yes I would probably get more
views and subscribers if I cater to my
audience more but I think I'm good you
know what I think I'm alright I think
I'll be okay
either way and that doesn't mean I don't
care about what you guys say it's just I
want to make stuff for that I'm proud of
so this title and thumbnail it early had
nothing to do with the actual video I
remember this comment got a lot of
comments about this because the title
and thumbnail was something that was in
the end of the video like the vlog for
example what do you guys think about the
title and thumbnail I just try and do
something that people would want to
click on I feel like I have the content
and the entertainment is there I just
need to get people in the video I don't
feel like I'm misleading anyone you know
what I mean there's a thin line that you
kind of have to pick what happened to
the dogs I I'm guessing you're asking
about Maya Maya lost her eye before we
got her and she's not bothered with it
so it's okay don't shave your bird
I won't your girlfriend is adorable what
are you hitting on my girl [ __ ] you
don't use adblock I use adblock there's
a lot of [ __ ] annoying website I
greenlight it on YouTube which basically
means it's not all on YouTube if
everyone used adblock I wouldn't have be
able to do what I'm doing and that
doesn't mean I only make videos just to
make money I made videos over a year
before I made any money on them I just
wasn't able to do it on such a frequent
basis even if YouTube turned off their
way of making like ads to ad revenue I
would still make videos
I just wouldn't be able to do it and at
the same frequency as now I have a lot
of respect for what I do and even though
my channel is so silly and so stupid I
take it very seriously that was a total
different answer to the question but I
hope it makes sense the people that
filmed it him must feel so weird I bet
they do feel weird we also have a lot of
fun shooting together like it's not some
weird porno where okay it is the weird
porno blastin it I'm sure a lot of
people can relate PewDiePie to filthy
Frank I've drawn a lot of inspiration
for them filthy Frank and I do think we
have a lot of similarities but I'm
nowhere near as insane as that guy gray
day under a destroyed you bro I love
this like I can literally tweet someone
I know like a half joke and people will
just be like oh oh [ __ ] he did not say
that that [ __ ] got roasted like gray
didn't even say anything bad I think or
because of these three idiots
he better not [ __ ] house alright
thank you so much for watching this
video leave a like if you enjoyed I got
a new challenge for you pose something
on tumblr hashtag it
PewDiePie I will review my tumblr in the
next video and if it's only dad and Phil
I swear to [ __ ] god make me laugh
make me cry make me want to die cuz I'm
PewDiePie [ __ ] thank you both so much
for watching thank you for leaving your
comments
I love reading comments I really
appreciate appreciate you for being
interactive and not just watching my
videos and as always you're ready for
this sale sim rush you see this brag get
in here quick
yeah yeah that's some good [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] up yeah I don't like this one
Japan you straight-up weird man what the
[ __ ] is